you talk about the being on hits you
know your own grace is out of here on
killing Eve but there's another thing
you were in that people come up to ask
you about isn't there which oh this is
actually quite from from the past when I
it was actually I think my first
American movie I that I that I that I
shot oh no no no I I'm thinking about
you know what I was thinking about mr.
bean Mr Bean who is obviously a very
very very famous character for you that
that movie his first movie was my very
first what my very first gig in America
in America
you're in you're in the mr. bean movie
dude I mean I wish that you could just
show yeah
right now I'm in mr. bean it was my very
first gig in in LA in Iran it on a film
in LA so we shot that it must have been
the fall of 95 and I met Rowan and
Harris you in fantastic cast and Peter
Peter McNichol who is just a genius
I was very young I was probably around
23 24 and I had just come to LA and it
was recently on television and I was
like I cannot believe my hair but that
was I gotta tell you such a great
experience I there's a scene when we're
all together in a conference room and
Rowan is Rowan was doing his thing and
we could never get through a take we
could never get through it take and it
was such a great rich experience for me
shooting that was my first immersed big
film okay we've got we've got the pit
this is you we found it but this is this
is so live you speak we find we've got
the picture there she is what that is
elaborate hair but also is that great
that you know because someone else might
have come to LA and been in the mr. bean
movie but they're never being in other
things so they'd hook get to look back
and you know enjoy it it's interesting
it's like when you just if you can just
hang on if you can just stick around and
hang on it's amazing all the things that
uh you learn that come back to you and
that you can then you
referred to many years later on your
shelf
[Music]